bueno no recuerdo yo
con mucha emoción porque
este Yo tuve la sensación y el momento
de crecer en el fútbol jugando el primer
partido como profesional contra Pelé
este en Argentina y eso para mí fue un
un elevador no en mi carrera y lo conocí
muy bien porque Gracias tuvimos varios
partidos que jugamos contra y como
persona como jugador como jugador de
fútbol no creo que haya habido alguien
tan importante y no creo que vaya a
haber algo tan importante con tu pelea
por qué porque
tenía todas las las cualidades todas las
calidades y él aprovechaba los momentos
y jugaba al fútbol que lo que mucha
gente no entiende principalmente hoy no
se entiende Lo que jugaba y jugar al
fútbol es divertirse también dentro de
campo así Yo también lo hacía más o
menos en ese estilo O sea no era un
jugador que
usaba la violencia para parar el jugador
si no usaba la picardía y este y con eso
también conseguimos en con varios
jugadores hacia la mitad también como
papeles conversábamos antes y después
los partidos
atilio Pelé nunca jugó en Europa y aún
así es conocido en todo el mundo cómo se
explica esta situación que sea tan
conocido en el resto del planeta cuando
él solamente pues estuvo en esta parte
del del hemisferio pues
y era el comienzo de la de las
transmisiones por televisión de radio
Así es cuando pelea comenzó no y y la
historia nos dice nos cuenta no que en
Europa
se crió una fama mayor todavía por causa
de que se escuchaba mucho la radio y y
nos dejó después que viajaba con Santos
fue que quedó conocido totalmente no ahí
se se conoció el fútbol de pelé porque
antiguamente cuando peleé hacía sus
grandes jugadas no se conseguía mirar
todavía la televisión este
radio y entonces yo creo que más por eso
no que cuando Santos comenzó a viajar y
hacer combinado a viajar por Europa o
sea creo ese ese ese pensamiento de las
personas no de conocerlo y de tenerlo
cerca o sea tener historia en todos
lados no solo dentro de fútbol de fuera
del fútbol o sea peleé para una guerra
se le expulsó árbitros porque no es
impropio no pero él hizo cosas que no
creo que alguien más vaya a hacer el
resto de la de mi vida no este yo creo
que Pelé también fue una excelente
persona porque porque le gustaba jugar
al fútbol no era violenta Ahora cuando
lo agredían el quedaba violento Sí pero
tentaba siempre hacer lo mejor posible
que era hacerle diferente para
demoralizarlo y no pegar esa era lo más
importante pero también se defendía
bastante pero yo fui un jugador bastante
clásico y me di muy bien con él me vi
muy bien así la amistad en la conversa
antes después los partidos en el respeto
que tuvimos los dos
y hoy me siento muy emocionado por eso